it's like a homecoming for you Tom your
very first watch was a tag when it comes
to endorsements you were very particular
Under Armor now tag herbes you look at
other athletes they've got twice as many
endorsement deals
why tag why do this now at this stage of
my career I think I've just focused on
the things that you know are part of my
belief system companies that are really
aligned with things that I enjoy and
things that I believe in so my first
watch was a tag you know they came to me
and they said what you think about this
I thought it was something that was just
a perfect fit so I'm glad it worked out
when you think about what do people see
in Tom Brady today take yourself back
when you were the one hundred and
ninety-ninth draft pick what didn't
people see then take us to today one of
the greatest football players of all
time
well tell you it's gone fast I mean I
can't I still can't believe like you
know already this season I'm like well I
already five games into the year I mean
it's unbelievable how the time has just
flown by and I still approach it like I
did that first year I mean it's I also
you know I got my opportunity you know
when someone else got injured and you
know you never know when your last
game's gonna be so you just enjoy the
moments you enjoy the years and when you
enjoying or having fun like I'm having
and we won they go really fast so I
think a lot of things have changed since
then obviously like everyone's life you
evolve over you know certain periods of
time and you know I'm at a great place I
love what I'm doing I love my career I
love you know my family's great so I'm
very blessed when you think about these
endorsements they almost seem like
partnerships you're coming through a
year of a lot of tumultuous Ness and
when you look at partners you've had tag
is brand new for you Under Armour's a
partner that really doubled down on you
so don't look at this like they're
endorsements or do you feel like you are
part of these brands absolutely and I
think that's the commitment that I want
to make to them as well and that's you
know certainly what I've done with Tag
Heuer obviously with Under Armour what
Kevin's accomplished has been amazing
what on how it has done is been
amazing so you're right I mean I think
those three brands in particular have
done an incredible job in the market
they got great products they're
continuing to innovate you know it's
exciting off the field to be a part of
things that I enjoy also Adweek named
you Teflon Tom what does that mean what
does that mean I don't I hope that's a
compliment yeah way either way you know
I think that like I said I'm blessing a
lot of ways so you know I don't sweat
the small stuff and you know things that
I may deal with personally or
professionally to me a lot of times our
small stuff it may seem like it's
blowing out of proportion and certainly
the success that we've had as a team you
know leads to a lot of things and and
you welcome those things I'm glad we're
relevant I'm glad that people talk about
it talk about different things that have
happened in my life because that means
we're doing something good you're
definitely doing something good you're
winning this weekend you're heading to
Indianapolis you're gonna play the Colts
how do you feel about this well I'm
excited to want revenge I know they do I
know they do but at the same time you
know I think for me I always approach my
job the same way and you know I'm trying
to be the best I can be every single
week and I tried I was that bad I tried
to be that way last week trying to be
that the week before and I've done that
throughout the course of my entire
career my teammates have done that too
it's not like one week in the regular
season you Wow this week's really
important look they're all important
there's only 16 of them you don't just
have guts on the field rule yourself
didn't come out of thin air when you
look at the things you say who you are
in your own time standing up for Donald
Trump why he's a friend that's why
because you know friends are important
in life and I've known him for a very
long time so certainly you know
friendships you endure over the courses
of long periods of time and he's someone
I played a lot of golf with and he's a
lot of fun to play golf with although I
might rather be on his team when we play
golf and be against themselves safe to
say golf's her favorite sport other than
football I'd say it's a hobby at this
point I wish I got a chance I was
something my dad and I love to do when I
was younger I had three older sisters so
the only time we could sneak
away from the house was to play golf
with my dad which was you know my dad
was my idol growing up is someone I
always love to you know spend as much
time as I could with so I think part of
that is you know instilled in me and
that's a great place for me to go and
bring my kids out there - who's your
favorite football player growing up I
grew up in the Bay Area so there was two
great quarterbacks I had you know Joe
Montana and then there was a transition
in Steve Young so those two were you
know growing up in the Bay Area at that
time that was a magical time in my life
that's when I fell in love - sport so
got to go to those games I was playing
football in the parking lot you know it
was a great childhood Tom you are an
important and iconic brand you've
partnered with an iconic brand but just
today we saw you make comments that
might make some people say hmm so to
feel negative about things like
coca-cola which we all grew up drinking
and frosted flakes does it make you
nervous because Tom Brady is an
all-american brand and so are they well
everyone has their different belief
systems I think everyone has their
different opinions of you know those
types of things that you talked about
certainly as an athlete I care very much
what I put into my body I think that I'm
38 years old I'm not 22 anymore oh good
you're very sweet thanks but I you know
all those things are important and all
the little things add up to be big
things so when I'm trying to accomplish
things professionally that you know in a
lot of ways you're in unchartered
territory so I've got to do things
differently and I got to evolve over
time I've got the things that may have
worked in the past maybe don't work as
you move forward so the lessons that
I've learned through my own trial and
error I think I'm at that point in my
career I'm very efficient with what I'm
doing so I try to eat healthy I try to
get the right amount of rest I try to do
the right types of exercise so I can be
on the field and be available I team I
try to be you know as productive this
time in my career as I was earlier so
all right I'm gonna see how fast you are
I'm gonna give you word and you give me
the first thing that comes to mind
Thursday night games love them transit
Entenmann's love it me too hugs love
them jamie dimon ah great guy
smartwatches
very very cool though I can't quite
figure him out yet toughest defenseman
you face oh man's long list
IDI read he was one of my nemesis's
Manning
he's great great player Peyton or Eli
both both Peyton was more my era Eli's
got the best of us a few times but
Payne's one of the best ever play
Michigan under Jim Harbaugh let's go
even though it's a Nike team
well then maybe they made a bad decision
there really I think the Wolverines made
a bad decisions there you go
Kevin Plank oh man
one of my heroes Donald Trump one of my
great friends
Jordan speith a beast favorite movie
Braveheart nice perfect oh I got one
more Mike Bloomberg uh he just did an
amazing job with New York City there you
go
and Tom Brady just did an amazing job at
that interview yeah